- La mairesse de Longueuil nous
a parlé hier en disant que ceetn
a mis dans l'esprit de la ville
de Longueuil un point final à
une hitions incroyables l'an
dernier. En novembre dernier, la
ville annonce qu'on doit battre
des cerfs de Virginie dans le
parc. On a vu cette montée. Luc,
on, s'est appuyé par des
faits elle ne doit pas reculer?s
c'est une décision que devra
prendre à répétition parce que
les chevreuils vont continuer de
Mais elle a prie la bonne
décision et je suis contente de
voir que la table de
bernaches. J'ai visité des parcs
à cause de la présence des
bernaches. J'ai souvent que
humains prennent la place des
animaux, mais il faut auss
garder des parcs en ville.
Lorsque les animaux prennent
trop de place, il faut les
- Il y avait une levée de
boucliers. Je reque
j'avais osé direela.
Il y en a trop, il mange lesst n
peu la victoire de la sciede lae
contre le côté irrationnel.
C'est ce qu'on aime les animaux,
mais ça dépend dent.
- Je mécision. Si on
veut atteindre un équilibre dans
le pare de la quantité
de che Longueuil, mais
est-ce que c'est seulement le
problème des chevreuils? Est-ce
est parce que pendant la
pandémie, les citoyens ont
davantage en prenant des marges,
tant des sentiers et en
allant briser la fournée
Lafleur. Il y a beaucoup...
- est-ce que vous êtes en train
de médire que vous les
laisseriez croître?
- Non, mais je me demande si
c'est la bonne décision de
vont revenir l'année prochaine.
Ils vont continuer quand mtemps
de lire cette semaine ce qui se
passe t j'ai regardé
ce quinimal, qui
disait qu'il y a des solutions
qui mévoir leur place.
Les stériliser de façon
là soit stérilisés.
t cela qu'ils veulent
faire, ils veulent stériliser la
dizaine qu'il laisserait dans le
les déplacer et les envoyer
Félicien avait dit qu'ils
étaient prêts à les prendre.
dit que s'il les déplace, et
votre traumatisée peut être
mauvais. J'ai mis avoir une
chance de vivre que de laisser
tout de suite sans savoir si on
peut continuer. Est-ce qu'on est
allé au bout des choses pour
avoir cet équilibre? Je trouve
une solution peut-être trop
facile de dire qu'on les tue et
qu'on n'en parle plus, mais ça
va continuer et est-ce que la
faune
régénérer? C'est des questions
que je me pose.
- Je pense qu'il y a une
différence entre traiter les
animaux de façon humaine et les
traiter comme des humains. C'est
pas pareil. Abattre un animal en
prenant soin, en s'assurant
qu'il ne souffre pas, en sachant
qu'il y a des dizaines de
milliers de chèvres qui sontabae
semble être une façon humaine de
les traiter. Vouloir les conserver
m'interroge. La population de
chevreuils au Québec n'est pas
menacée. On parle de quelques
individus seulement.
Personnellement, je trouve que
c'est irrationnel. Les villes
éliminent des dizaines de
milliers de rats par année. Je
sais que Lauras est moins beau
que le chevreuil, mais on les
élimine sans aucun
questionnement. Le chevreuil et
le beluga, c'est cute, mais il y
a toutes sortes d'espèces
animales. Il faut être cohérent.
Si on reuil
comme une espèce animale qui
n'est pas en danger, il y a des
espèces animales qui sont en
tte faux grillon
juste à côté. Le chevreuil n'est
pas en danger. Il faut bien le
traiter, l'abattre de la façon
la plus humaine possible, mais
pour moi la question ne se pose
- Est-ce que c'est parce que
c'est un animal très joli que ça
vous fait douter?
- Je suis la petite cousine de
Michel Pageau, l'homme qui par
Loulou en Abitibi. Il a fait
refuge avec des animaux blessés.
J'ai fait parti
génération-là.
- Le problème, c'est qu'il n'y a
pas de loup, ils
prédateur.
- Si on veut les transporter
ailleurs pour qu'il puisse
continuer à vivre ailleurs,
qu'on ne me dise pas qu'ils vont
............
à lire le
rapport qui était donné la
mairesse. Ils ont quand même
tourné pas mal toutes les
pierres et le comité disait
qu'il n'y a pas d'autre façon.ps
déplacer. Débat d'idées. Un mot sur les policiers.
La mairesse de Montréal nous avait dit
250 policiers de plus. Ce qu'on
comprend, on n'avait pas lu les
petits caractères en bas, c'est
250 policiers qui seront
engagés...
- la mairesse avait été claire
et avait parlé de 250 policiers
de nouveau supplémentaire. Elle
a joué avec la vérité. En ce
moment, c'est l'étude des
crédits budgétaires. On est en
et
qu'on va déposer incessamment et
qui va être voté en janvier.
C'est très cher d'engager 250
policiers de plus. Si on
remplace 150 policiers à la
retraite par 150 nouveaux
policiers, on fait des
économies, parce que les gens
qui partent à la retraite
gagnent plus d'argent que les
nouveaux policiers. On var une n
peut y arriver avec le mécanisme
d'économie qu'on va faire. Maise
remplacement des 150 à la
retraite, c'est un coût
gigantesque et Mme Plante sous-.
- C'est encore une promesse qui
n'est pas tenue dans son premier
sans jour. Il fa
la dernière campagne où elle
avait dit qu'elle augmenterait
pas les taxes et c'est la
première chose qu'elle a faite.
C'est exactement la même chose.
La limite maximale prévue par la
loi de la police de 4800
policiers. Ce que Denis Coderre
avait dit avec son équipe, c'est
: on va remplacer ceux qui
ais on
n'en rajoute 250 nouveaux parce
qu'on n'en a besoin. Il avait
estimé à 110 millions. Valérie
Plante a dit qu'elle allait
faire la même chose sauf ques st
dit qu'elle va remplacer ceux
qui vont partir à la retraite,
donc on va en avoir remplacé les
250, mais c'est pas 250
nouveaux. Ces 250 qui sont là.
La loi de la police permet
d'avoir 250 nouveaux. On pde sée
dire qu'on a passé de policiers
et là, on dit que c'est pas ça
qu'on a dit.
- Si je peux permettre un bémol,
je ne pense pas qu'il manque de
policiers Montréal. On n'en a
plus qu'à Toronto. Mais ça
n'enlève pas le fait qu'elle a
bel et bien dit qu'elle en
engage
- Mais elle ne fera pas, encore!
Promesse brisée en 10 ou 15
jours, c'était sa dernière
promesse et c'est la première
qu'elle enlève de son calepin.
Elle ne l'a pas fait et encoree
politique et de cynisme...
- il y a des gens d'autres
médias qui ont reçu des menacese
yang. Il n'y a pas eu de menaces
de mort. Il y a une menace sur
Facebook jugée sérieuse. Edoit e
demain